الشبكات العصبية هي فئة قوية من خوارزميات التعلم الآلي
وهي تأتي بأشكال وأنواع كثيرة
ما في إمكانية نعطي الشبكات العصبية حقها
في فيديو تعريفي
زي هذا، هنا رح نتعرف بس على بعض المكونات الأساسية
للشبكة العصبية وطريقة عملها بشكل عام
عشان نفهم كيف يقدر الحوسبة الكمومية يساهم في هذا
الشبكة العصبية هي رسم بياني متصل من الخلايا العصبية
الخلية العصبية هي في الأساس مجرد شيء يحمل رقمًا
وهذا الرقم يُسمى في الغالب التنشيط، يعني كم
الخلية العصبية مفعّلة أو غير مفعّلة
الخلايا العصبية مرتّبة في طبقات
والطبقة الأولى هي طبقة الإدخال
والأخيرة هي طبقة الإخراج
وبينهم في طبقات للمعالجة تُسمى
الطبقات المخفية، تنشيط
طبقة الإدخال بيُحمَّل مباشرة من البيانات اللي رح تتحلل
مثل درجة تظليل البكسل في الصورة
تنشيطات الطبقة المخفية التالية بتتحدد
من خلال الخلايا العصبية في طبقة الإدخال
ومن خلال الأوزان اللي ترمزها الخطوط الرابطة بين كل الخلايا
في طبقة الإدخال وكل الخلايا في
الطبقة التالية، بمعنى آخر نحدد التنشيط
لخلية عصبية في الطبقة المخفية
عن طريق مجموع موزون لكل
تنشيطات الإدخال، ونقدر
كمان نطبق انحياز يعني إزاحة
ممكن نريد تنشيط خلية عصبية
في الطبقة المخفية مش بس لو كان المجموع الموزون
موجبًا، بل بس لو تجاوز عتبة كبيرة
بعدين غالبًا نطبق دالة معقدة عشان نحصل على تنشيط
بين صفر وواحد زي المماس الزائدي
أو أحيانًا بشكل مختلف
وحدة خطية معدّلة، ما تحتاج تقلق
كثير على هذي الأشياء الحين، الشيء
الوحيد المهم تلاحظه على هذي الدوال
هو إنها غير خطية
عشان الشبكة كلها تحتوي على مكونات خطية
وغير خطية في نفس الوقت
نفس المجموع الموزون للتنشيطات، هذي المرة
بدءًا من تنشيطات
أول طبقة مخفية والأوزان الجديدة
يمتد إلى الطبقة المخفية التالية
وهذا يستمر حتى الطبقة الأخيرة وهي الإخراج
طبقة الإخراج فيها خلايا عصبية تقابل
الفئات والتنشيطات تخبرنا
كم الشبكة متأكدة من التصنيف
فمثلًا فئات الإخراج في تحليل الصور ممكن تكون
كلب وقطة وهامستر وغيرها
وتنشيط بقيمة 0.95 على
خلية الكلب العصبية يدل على درجة عالية من اليقين بأن
الصورة لكلب، ممكن تبدأ شبكتك العصبية
بمجموعة عشوائية من الأوزان
والانحيازات، أو من تكوين بداية معقول ومعروف
لكن الفكرة بعدين هي التحقق من
مدى كفاءة شبكتك العصبية في تصنيف الأشياء
وتحسينها، نستخدم دالة التكلفة لوصف
كيف تنحرف شبكتنا العصبية عن
التصنيف الصحيح، وهذا يتضمن أخذ
الفرق بين القيمة الفعلية للصورة
مثلًا قيمة واحد على الخلية العصبية
للكلب وصفر على كل خلايا الإخراج الأخرى
والقيم المتوقعة
ونجمع على كل الفئات
فنتابع مش بس إذا كانت الفئة الصحيحة هي
الأكثر تنشيطًا، بل نقدر
كمان نتابع إذا كانت التنشيطات الخاطئة تنخفض
ونجمع على كل الأمثلة في مجموعة التدريب
ونحصل على تكلفة، ثم
نغيّر المعاملات زي الأوزان في كل طبقة
بين كل الخلايا العصبية والانحيازات على كل حدة
يُستخدم روتينات التحسين الكلاسيكية
للبحث عن حد أدنى محلي في دالة التكلفة
لو ما اتخذنا إجراء لتقليل تعقيد هذا
تقدر تتخيل كيف
فضاء المعاملات اللي أنشأناه هنا هائل
تخيل شبكة عصبية مصممة لتحليل صور بـ
ألف بكسل بس، هذي الشبكة العصبية ممكن تحتوي على ألف
خلية إدخال وطبقة مخفية واحدة بس
وإخراج ثنائي زي قطة أو كلب
وهذا أبسط حالة ممكنة
ومع ذلك يقابل ألف في ألف
أي مليون وزن بين طبقتي الإدخال والمخفية
وألفين إضافيين بين
الطبقتين المخفية والإخراج
وربما كمان ألف أو
أكثر من الانحيازات، فهذي الشبكة العصبية البسيطة تقابل
أكثر من مليون معامل، بالرغم من إنه بالإنصاف
الخوارزميات الحديثة عادةً تسوي تبسيطات
في الشبكات العصبية الكلاسيكية
وفي مجالات كاملة مخصصة لجعل هذا التصغير
ممكنًا وحتى فعّالًا
لكن الحقيقة تبقى إن هذه مشكلة
عالية الأبعاد جدًا
وتدريب شبكة عصبية
ممكن يكون مستهلك للوقت جدًا
ومكلف، الشبكة العصبية الكمومية أو QNN
تعمل بتحميل بيانات الإدخال أولًا
ثم تطبيق quantum circuits
المقابلة للأوزان بين الطبقات
وأخيرًا طبقة قياس
بعض النقاط المهمة في هذا، البيانات
التحميل والأوزان هي عمليات خطية
لكن القياسات هي غير خطية
فكما في الشبكات العصبية الكلاسيكية عندنا
مكونات خطية وغير خطية كلاهما
كمان دوائر الأوزان
لا تزال فيها معاملات تغييرية
فلا يزال هناك تصغير كلاسيكي يجب تنفيذه
بالطبع هذا خدش السطح بس في موضوع الشبكات العصبية الكمومية
لكن نأمل إنك تواصل تعلمك عن تطبيقات
الشبكات العصبية الكمومية
وتطبيقات التعلم الآلي الكمومي الأخرى
مع IBM Quantum